Speaker 1: OK, before we go to break, I do want to
squeeze in just one other one of these stories. It
really appears as though being a right wing radio
host and or a right wing pastor can be very, very
dangerous. Bob Enyart, conservative, firebrand
and pastor Big Antibalas dies of covid-19.
The Denver Post is reporting that the pastor of
the Denver Bible Church and indelible talk show
host has died from covid Bob Enyart was one of the
smartest and without question, why is this person
I've known? Said Fred Williams, his co-host
on the real science radio show Real Science.
Can you imagine? Enyart and his wife refused
to get the vaccine due to abortion concerns.
In October, Enyart successfully sued the
state over mass mandates and capacity limits
in churches of rare legal victory against public
health mandates instituted during the pandemic.
You might be saying abortion, what but what are
you talking about? I checked out the website and
they have a section covid vaccines where they say
this is from last month. Guys, guys dead. Now,
Bob and Sheryl have sworn off taking the Pfizer,
Moderna and Johnson vaccines because as those
firms admit, they tested the three products on
the cells of aborted babies. There are, however,
vaccines being developed morally, though none
are scheduled to be available until the end of
this year. Our friends over at Kog for life
drug list, these coming ethical vaccines,
Merck, Sanofi and from Novavax. The Charlotte
Lozier Institute reports Inovio and biotech are
also producing vaccines developed without fetal
tissue. So while it is not inherently sinful
to take an amorally developed vaccine. We urge
everyone to boycott Pfizer, Moderna and Johnson
to further increase social tension, wow and
put pressure on the child killers. Remember,
many institutions and celebrities who have
been pro-choice all along are now calling to
legalize infanticide, which they call after birth
abortion. So there's no bottom to their Abis.
Sanofi Pasteur has discontinued using fetal
tissue for the polio vaccine. Well, so maybe
soon they'll allow people to get the polio vaccine
at this church. These people are causing death.
He died. He died. Now, another one of these
guys who died, but they are also causing death
elsewhere by convincing people of this stuff. So
another antitax radio host who is also a pastor
just last week saying no Pfizer, no Moderna, no,
no Johnson, as they call it. He has now died. What
can you say? What can you say? We'll have more
on that on our Instagram at David Pakman show.